berthet il vient tout juste de paraître
le 177e numéro du journal du lycée en
raison de la crise sanitaire c'est la
seule édition du mur cette année au lieu
des 3 à 4 habituellement elle était très
spécial puisque nombre de ces travaux
ont été faits pendant qu'on était chez
soi c'était beaucoup travaillé à la
maison aussi
beaucoup de textes sur justement le
monde d'après après ben justement cette
crise sanitaire
dans ce numéro du mur il est aussi
question de bijouterie dont les métiers
sont enseignés dans l'établissement une
très bonne chose parce que ça fait ça
fait vraiment découvrir notre métier aux
gens c'est important que ça continue
parce que on peut un peu certaines
personnes peuvent avoir des clichés sur
la bijouterie comme quoi
passé qu'un métier de femme alors que
non finalement c'est un métier
parfaitement mixte le mur avec ses 35
années d'existence est l'un des plus
anciens journaux lycéens de france 1993
a été décisive
grâce au programme d'échangé européen on
a constitué un réseau d'écoles de
bijouteries en europe d'une d'une
quinzaine d'écoles avec lesquels on
travaille aujourd'hui encore à distance
depuis le début de cette pandémie mais
avec lesquels on espère bien retrouver
des actions de mobilité de deux
rencontres dès l'année prochaine en
étant passionné de bijouterie voir des
jeunes lycéens comme moi qui ont pu
voyager dans l'europe
enfin des stages en travers de la
bijouterie sama
j'étais impressionné et ça m'a donné
envie de m'impliquer encore plus pour
pouvoir bénéficier de ses voyages à
l'étranger aussi
cette ouverture sur le monde agite la
conscience des trente deux élèves de
l'équipe rédactionnelle elles forgent
leur esprit critique et fera d'eux
peut-être de futurs journalistes
d'opinion les habitudes quotidiennes
cette crise nous a obligés à nous poser
des questions sur notre manière de vivre
et de consommer personne ne peut dire
quel sera le monde d'après pourtant il
est essentiel de penser au futur
après cette crise planétaire et
d'envisager à l'échelle mondiale une
relance écologique